it's considered the last pocket of
ukrainian resistance in the shattered
city of mario poll
and the scene of heavy fighting for
weeks
ukrainian forces say russians are
attacking the azov stall steel factory
where civilians and soldiers are
sheltering in underground bunkers
some of the estimated 2 000 besieged
fighters including women sing in the
dark and wait
there's not enough food or ammunition
even if outnumbered they say they have
no intention of surrendering
heavy bloody fighting is going on for 71
days the defenders of the city have been
fighting single-handedly with
overpowering enemy forces
a three-day cease-fire was promised by
russia to allow civilians to escape
ukraine says the promise has been broken
some women children and elderly managed
to make it out earlier this week but
others remain trapped alongside
ukrainian soldiers
i really want my family to get out
but not the way we did it was a miracle
we managed to live on the verge of life
and death
ukraine's president is appealing for
help to get the others to safety
today i spoke to un secretary general
antonio gutierrez and we discussed what
we have already achieved and what is
still necessary to do to save mario paul
and the defenders of mario paul city
there is not a single day that i and my
team wouldn't do this and i'm grateful
to everybody who helps
the kremlin says accusations of broken
promises are propaganda
the ukrainian side and especially those
who are hiding in the azov style plant
are well known for producing an enormous
number of lies and fakes every day so we
should carefully filter all the
information we get from them
ukraine says russia is trying to destroy
the strategically important city in the
south
a ukrainian counter-offensive is
unlikely before the middle of the next
month when it hopes more weapons from
allies will have arrived
katya lopes
al jazeera
ukrainian officials and kramer tourists
say 25 people have been wounded in
russian shelling the eastern city is
near the front line of fighting in
donetsk province
russia has increased its bombardment of
ukrainian positions as part of its
donbass offensive
charles stratford is near where one of
the strikes hit
have a look at the size of this crater
that's got to be 10 to 15 feet deep
now local residents are saying that the
building the destroyed building that you
can see here
was an abandoned
building that was still under
construction
um
look at the thickness of the of the
masonry you can see obviously how
powerful
that that bomb attack was um right it's
going to pan up and you can see the
residential buildings this is a
so
so the military say is a purely
residential area there are hundreds of
flats
that
have had their windows
destroyed and as you can see
pretty much uh completely devastated and
this area has ride pounds around sweeps
around to
there's a playground here in the park
and you can see obviously the trees
there have been completely shredded this
was an incredible
incredibly powerful explosion residents
are saying that they heard this is one
of three explosions they heard in this
area last night at around 5am it is
incredible that nobody was killed in
these attacks we're hearing that at
least 25 people
were injured
and as i say earlier on this morning we
were at another attack nothing like on
on this scale what we do know though is
that russian forces certainly according
to the ukrainian military russian forces
are building up and the reinforcements
have gone in north of cremators indeed
north of the neighbouring city to hear
slavyansk around a town called isiam our
correspondent had
following developments near the hasan
region in southern ukraine
we're about two kilometers from the uh
front line north of the reson
region that's an area that has been
occupied
by russia
we met some people this morning who had
just arrived here on the ukrainian side
and they told us that they had to
actually walk up to 20 kilometers under
cover of darkness simply because the
russians wouldn't allow them to come to
the ukrainian side they told them if you
want to go to a safe area then you
should head south to the crimean
peninsula now the defense minister
in kiev is saying that russia is
preparing for a big push on the southern
front uh to in two directions to the
west to the city of nicolaev and to the
north to the city of krivi re certainly
people here say they have been more
shelling there was this morning uh some
pre-dawn the mayor tells us that cluster
bombs were found
he showed us some pictures we cannot
confirm that independently but certainly
when you walk around
again the scene of villages completely
abandoned people left
people do worry that this push will come
sooner rather than later those coming
out of her son are saying well they're
coming out as quick as possible because
life there has become
unbearable
they lack everything food medicine water
in many areas and also the currency is
about to change from the ukrainian
rivner to the russian
ruble
when you ask them what about talk about
imminent annexation of the region well
one man told us he didn't know exactly
what were the plans but certainly uh he
thought that those were
happening but he did say that the
russians will find no one there because
most of the people are trying to leave
as quick as possible